Yevgueni Prigozhin, el jefe del grupo Wagner,
ha sido ejecutado.
Todo apunta a que Vladímir Putin, al final,
cumplió su venganza.
Lo hizo exactamente 2 meses después de que
el grupo de mercenarios más famoso de Rusia
protagonizara un sonado alzamiento y marchara
sobre Moscú para denunciar el desastre en
Ucrania.
Pues bien, todo eso ahora ya es historia.
El jet comercial con matrícula RA-02795, propiedad del grupo Wagner,
se estrelló este miércoles 23 de agosto
de 2023 en la región de Tver tras haber despegado
de Moscú con dirección a San Petersburgo.
Este que veis en pantalla es el avión cayendo.
Pero, ¿qué pasó exactamente para que esta
aeronave terminara estrellándose contra el
suelo?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que, según afirman tanto los
propios entornos del grupo Wagner como fuentes
de inteligencia occidentales al Financial
Times, el avión podría haber sido abatido
ni más ni menos que por la defensa antiaérea
de Rusia.
Presumiblemente, en el aparato viajaban el
líder de Wagner, Yevgeny Prigozhin y su mano
derecha y responsable militar de la organización,
el comandante de Wagner, Dmitry Utkin.
Es decir, que estamos ante una clara ejecución.
Todo apunta a que tras asegurarse de que los
dos pesos pesados del grupo de mercenarios
volaban exactamente en el mismo avión, el
Kremlin decidió terminar con ellos por todo
lo alto.
Queridos amigos, amigas, podemos decir que
Prigozhin ha sido la viva imagen de la política
rusa de las últimas décadas.
De abrir a principios de los años 90 una
cadena de puestos de perritos calientes y
más tarde algún que otro restaurante, algo
mejor puesto - gracias a lo cual, por cierto,
hizo relación con el presidente ruso - este
magnate de la restauración terminó convirtiéndose
en todo un señor de la guerra.
Lideró la que probablemente es la empresa
de mercenarios más importante y conocida
de todo el planeta.
Con negocios en Rusia, África, Oriente Medio
y otras muchas partes del mundo, Prigozhin
llegó, incluso, a convertirse en una de las
caras más visibles de la brutal invasión
rusa de Ucrania.
Digamos que es la mejor representación posible
del capitalismo mafioso que impera en Rusia.
Sin embargo, ahora su historia ha llegado
a su fin.
Evidentemente, todavía son muchas las cosas
que no conocemos y que, quizás, no conozcamos
nunca, pero desde luego también hay cosas
que sí sabemos.
Queridos amigos, amigas, ¿Qué ha pasado
exactamente?
¿Por qué Vladímir Putin ha decidido cargarse
al jefe de los Wagner?
Y sobre todo, ¿por qué ha decidido hacerlo
ahora?
Y otra cuestión, no precisamente menor, ¿Qué
consecuencias puede tener toda esta historia?
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas.
Arranquemos.
Si hay una cosa clara en todo este asunto
es que a Putin nunca le ha temblado la mano
a la hora de perseguir y acabar con sus contrincantes.
Algo que, además, ha hecho habitualmente
de la forma más terrorífica posible.
Por ejemplo, el espía fugitivo ruso, Alexander
Litvinenko fue envenenado en la cafetería
de un hotel de Londres con polonio radiactivo;
el político opositor Boris Nemtsov fue asesinado
a tiros juntos a la Plaza Roja y la periodista
Anna
Politkovskaya fue ejecutada en su propio domicilio.
(Estos son tan solo 3 ejemplos de una larga,
larguísima lista de personas que han sido
envenenadas, tiroteadas o, simple y llanamente,
arrojadas por la ventana de algún edificio
alto de Rusia.
Una lista en la que podemos encontrar nombres
tan conocidos como el del líder opositor
Alexei Navalny o el de Sergei Skripal, un
antiguo espía doble afincado en Reino Unido.
Dos tipos que se salvaron por los pelos tras
ser brutalmente envenenados.
Porque, lo cierto es que en muchos casos las
ejecuciones promovidas por el presidente ruso
no solo buscan acabar con una determinada
persona, sino también infligir el mayor terror
posible al resto de potenciales adversarios.)
Pero, ojo, porque si esto ha sido una constante
en toda la era Putin, la guerra de Ucrania
ha marcado un antes y un después.
Ha sido todo un punto de inflexión.
Y es que, veréis, si hasta ahora la mayoría
de las víctimas habían sido oponentes formales
de Putin - personas que criticaban abiertamente
a su gobierno o que a ojos de Moscú habían
traicionado a Rusia - desde que Putin lanzara
al ejército ruso sobre Ucrania, el tipo de
víctimas ha cambiado.
En los últimos meses han perdido la vida
un montón de personas que formaban parte
de lo que podemos denominar como la élite
empresarial de Rusia.
Miembros que, tal vez, no eran del todo leales
o que manifestaban poco entusiasmo por la
guerra.
Hablamos de ejecutivos que en algunos casos
han llegado a perder la vida junto a sus familias
tanto en Rusia como fuera de Rusia.
Incluso, en Washington encontramos alguna
historia extraña como esta:
N1(Un crítico de Putin se cayó de un edificio
en Washington.
¿Fue realmente un suicidio?.
Politico)
Esto supone un importante salto, porque quiere
decir que ya ni siquiera los propios entornos
del gobierno están seguros.
Y ahora le ha llegado el turno a su última
víctima.
Esta que veis es una fotografía de la sede
del Grupo Wagner en San Petersburgo poco después
de que se conociera el fallecimiento de su
líder.
N2(El jefe del Grupo Wagner, Héroe de Rusia,
un verdadero patriota de su Patria, Yevgeny
Viktorovich Prigozhin, murió como resultado
de las acciones de los traidores a Rusia.
Grey Zone)
C1("Nadie debería sorprenderse.
La desastrosa guerra en Ucrania ha llevado
a un ejército privado a marchar sobre Moscú,
y ahora parece haber conducido a esto".
Adrienne Watson, Portavoz del Consejo de Seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos.)
El propio presidente Biden ha sido muy claro.
Y, ojo, porque todo esto de que no ha sido
una sorpresa es…
Estrictamente cierto.
Sin ir más lejos, apenas dos días antes
del suceso, el Departamento de Estado de los
Estados Unidos pidió por primera vez a sus
conciudadanos que abandonaran inmediatamente
Bielorrusia.
[¿Puede ser que tuvieran alguna información
y que se temieran las consecuencias en el
país a miles de soldados de Wagner?]
Sea como sea, esto es lo que se publicaba
el día 13 de agosto, tan solo 10 días antes
de la ejecución.
N3(Experto: El líder del Grupo Wagner de
Rusia será asesinado por Putin o liderará
otro golpe de estado en un plazo de 6 meses.
SCMP)
C2(Putin salió a la televisión y llamó
traidor a Prigozhin.
Todo el mundo sabe lo que hacen con los 'traidores',
y Putin no lo ha hecho.
Pero quiere verlo muerto.
Christo Grozev, periodista del muy respetado
medio de investigación Bellingcat)
Vale, Putin quería verle fuera de juego, de eso cabían pocas
dudas y hoy ya ninguna.
No olvidéis que hace exactamente 2 meses
antes del derribo del avión, Prigozhin encabezó
un motín contra la cúpula del Kremlin.
Un motín durante el que llegó a marchar
sobre Moscú, durante el cual su ejército
privado derribó varias aeronaves rusas y
donde, además, para colmo, el jefe de los
Wagner desacreditó la guerra en Ucrania.
Como todos recordaréis, al final la sublevación
se paró tras alcanzarse un acuerdo intermediado
por el presidente bielorruso, Alexander Lukashenko.
Los Wagner acordaron poner fin a su motín
a cambio de indultos, de poder continuar con
sus negocios y de tener un refugio seguro
en Bielorrusia.
Y ahora ya lo veis…
Una vez más la lección parece clara: nunca
te fíes de Vladímir Putin.
Un tipo que al poco de producirse el derribo
no ocultaba su enorme satisfacción.
En esta imagen que veis en pantalla, el presidente
ruso ya sabía que el avión de Wagner había
sido derribado.
No me digáis que no se le veía contento.
El plan había salido a las mil maravillas.
La purga estaba prácticamente terminada.
C3("Putin es el último apóstol de la venganza
[...] .Si yo fuera Prigozhin, no despediría
a mi catador de comida".
William Burns, director de la CIA)
Y no hablamos solo de Wagner.
El mismo miércoles 23 de agosto, unas horas
antes del derribo del avión, la agencia oficial
rusa RIA Nóvosti, confirmó la destitución
de Sergei Surovíkin, también conocido como
el General Armageddon, uno de los pesos pesados
de las fuerzas armadas rusas y el jefe de
las fuerzas aeroespaciales.
¿El motivo?
Se sospecha que mantenía estrechos lazos
con Prigozhin.
De hecho, Surovikin ya fue detenido tras la
sublevación de los Wagner.
La pregunta es, ¿fue esta la pieza que falló
aquellos días 23 y 24 de junio?
Eso quizás nunca lo sepamos, pero sea como
sea si algo está claro que Putin ha dado
un golpe en la mesa.
Y, sí, vale, todos podíamos imaginar que
tarde o temprano el presidente ruso intentaría
vengarse…
Pero, ¿por qué acabar con Prigozhin?
¿Y por qué hacerlo justamente ahora?
¿Qué gana el presidente ruso con todo esto?
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener esta ejecución?
Pues…
Veámoslo.
T1(EL MOMENTO PRECISO)
Queridos amigos, Wagner se había convertido
en toda una molestia para el presidente ruso.
Putin necesitaba sí o sí quitárselos de
en medio.
¿Por qué?
Pues…
En primer lugar, porque el hecho de que Prigozhin
siguiera paseándose por Rusia era una auténtica
vergüenza para Putin y una clara muestra
de debilidad.
El jefe de los Wagner le había retado y le
había humillado delante de toda Rusia y de
todo el mundo con su marcha sobre Moscú.
Y, claro, pensadlo bien, ningún dictador
puede permitirse el lujo de tolerar semejante
comportamiento.
Si lo hace, antes o después, otros repetirán
la jugada.
Pero es que, además, las cosas en Rusia no
van particularmente bien.
Muchos oligarcas y muchos militares están
terriblemente descontentos con todo lo que
ha supuesto la dichosa invasión de Ucrania.
En este sentido, la ejecución de Prigozhin
es un claro aviso a navegantes: Si oasis meteros
con el líder pagaréis las consecuencias.
(Prigozhin no solo era un mercenario, su grupo
operaba un montón de negocios diferentes.
Desde una fábrica de chocolate en San Petersburgo
o una destilería de Vodka hasta minas de
oro, agencias de comunicación y desinformación
y empresas de petróleo y gas.
En cierta forma, muchos oligarcas pueden verse
reflejados en él.
Y el hecho de haber derribado el avión puede
no ser algo casual.
Esta ejecución no solo ha sido muy visible,
sino que además en sí mismo también es
un mensaje para las élites de Rusia.
Élites que, habitualmente, se mueven en aviones
privados…
Es decir, el mensaje es claro: si se enfrentan
a Putin, nunca más estarán seguros.)
Ahora bien, estas son las razones, pero, ¿por
qué Putin lo ha hecho exactamente ahora?
¿Acaso ha sido simplemente porque ha tenido
la oportunidad?
Puede ser, pero también, hay algunos hechos
que pueden haber acelerado la toma de esta
decisión.
Por ejemplo, puede que sea una coincidencia
o puede que no, pero lo cierto es que en las
semanas anteriores se estaban produciendo
importantes cambios en Wagner.
El grupo parecía estar reestructurándose.
Cientos de soldados estaban abandonando Bielorrusia,
al parecer para incorporarse a las misiones
de Wagner en África, un lugar mucho más
lucrativo.
Hablamos tal vez de unas 1.000 o 1.400 unidades.
Y de hecho, el último vídeo en el que vimos
al propio Prigozhin fue precisamente en África.
¿El problema?
Pues que si Putin quería vengarse, y recordad
que era algo que necesitaba hacer, la huida
de los Wagner a África podría complicar
sus planes.
Además, el grupo podría utilizar esta aventura
para fortalecerse y ser un rival más desafiante.
Eso por no hablar de lo que podría suponer
para la imagen pública, si los Wagner lograran
algún tanto militar.
Las comparaciones serían odiosas.
Y de hecho esto nos lleva al segundo motivo
que tal vez explique por qué se decidió
acabar de una vez por todas con este tema.
Y es que…
Fijaos atentamente en este vídeo.
En él, veis la bandera ucraniana ondeando
sobre el disputado enclave de Robotyne.
Una posición que, comenzó a lucharse en
junio y que ahora le permite a la artillería
ucraniana atacar Tokmak, el siguiente paso
necesario en su avance hacia Melitopol.
Sí, la contraofensiva ucraniana ha sido más
lenta de lo esperado, hablaremos de ello muy
pronto aquí en VisualPolitik, pero lo cierto
es que en los días anteriores al derribo
del avión, las tropas ucranianas lograron
por fin algunos avances notables.
(Por ejemplo, la 47 Brigada Mecanizada de
Ucrania con apoyó de la 82 brigada de asalto
aéreo, logró romper las líneas defensivas
cerca de Robotyne, lo que precipitó la caída
de esta localidad.
Ahora esta posición le permite al ejército
ucraniano lanzar operaciones contra líneas
de defensa relativamente más débiles.
Y de hecho, los rusos, según informaciones
del Instituto para la Guerra, los rusos están
intentando fortalecer posiciones defensivas
a casi 30 km del frente actual.
Es decir, que esperan que las tropas ucranianas
puedan superar sus posiciones y avanzar.)
Lógicamente, esto es un problema y grande
para Putin…
O al menos lo era.
Prigozhin se había apuntado el tanto de Bajmut
y encima le había retado.
Cualquier traspié grave en Ucrania habría
sido un golpe muy fuerte para el Kremlin.
Se les vería como los perdedores, mientras
que el jefe de los Wagner podría reclamar
su estatus de vencedor.
Además, el parlamento ruso tuvo que aprobar
a finales de julio una nueva ley que autoriza
al Kremlin a enviar cientos de miles de hombres
más a la guerra.
Eso sí, esta vez la movilización será totalmente
muy diferente.
A partir de ahora el gobierno podrá enviar
solicitudes de reclutamiento confidenciales
a tantos hombres como considere necesario.
Asimismo, el límite de edad de las personas
que pueden ser llamadas a filas se ha ampliado
de los 27 a los 30 años y también se han
incrementado los castigos por negarse a servir
al ejército.
Y, claro, por muy confidencial o silencioso
que sea este proceso, no será nada popular.
Y con esas, mejor no tener mucha oposición.
Bueno, es que a Putin no le ha salido bien
ni siquiera esta jugada de despiste:
N4(21 de agosto de 2023: Fracasa la primera
misión lunar rusa en 47 años.
Reuters)
La primera misión lunar de Rusia en 47 años
fue un rotundo fracaso.
La nave rusa perdió el control y terminó
estrellándose contra la luna, mientras que
la India lograba poco después aterrizar su
propia nave espacial en la Luna sin ningún
problema.
C4("Este momento es inolvidable.
Es fenomenal.
Es el grito de victoria de una nueva India".
Narendra Modi, Primer Ministro de la India)
Así que, ¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Es muy posible que todos estos hechos hayan
influido y mucho a la hora de acelerar los
planes de Moscú.
Digamos que entre unas cosas y otras, dar
un golpe en la mesa y cargarse a Prigozhin
empezaba a parecer algo urgente.
Y eso es exactamente lo que han hecho.
Ahora bien, la última pregunta que tenemos
que responder es…
Exactamente, ¿qué consecuencias puede tener
este golpe?
¿Qué significa esta ejecución?
Pues…
Prestad mucha pero que mucha atención.
T2(LAS CONSECUENCIAS)
Queridos amigos, amigas, podemos encontrar
4 consecuencias directas de la caída de Prigozhin.
A corto y medio plazo parece claro que Putin
sale reforzado.
Le habían echado un pulso, no parecía estar
ganándolo y de repente, ¡Zas!
Tumbado.
El Kremlin parece estar cerrando sus grietas.
Por otro lado, la ejecución tal y como se
ha llevado a cabo va a multiplicar la paranoia
general y esto, esto también supone un problema
para el Kremlin.
Si hasta ahora ha quedado clara la burbuja
de información en la que vive Vladímir Putin,
ahora esto puede verse reforzado.
Trabajar con un autócrata despiadado no te
invita a mojarte mucho.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Nadie va a estar dispuesta a asumir responsabilidades.
Si en 2021 y 2022 le convencieron a Putin
de que Ucrania caería en 2 o 3 días, ahora
la cosa puede ponerse peor.
Por ejemplo, si ya era conocido que las personas
que forman parte del círculo íntimo de Putin
y de la élite rusa están incrementando su
seguridad, ahora eso puede dispararse.
Ya nadie está seguro en Rusia.
(Por otra parte, la caída de Prigozhin probablemente
marque el fin del Grupo Wagner.
Es muy probable que sus negocios terminen
siendo repartidos entre diferentes oligarcas
o directamente absorbidos por el gobierno
ruso.
Sin embargo, esto supondrá perder no solo
una importante estructura militar, sino que
también, muy probablemente, reducirá la
influencia de Rusia en África.)
Y por último, queda claro que negociar con
Putin no resulta útil.
No importa si hablamos de Prigozhin, de Ucrania
o de cualquier otro tema.
El presidente ruso rara vez cumple su palabra.
Sea como sea, con la información que tenemos
a la hora de preparar este vídeo, Putin parece
salir reforzado.
Pero ojo, que todavía tiene una guerra en
marcha, un creciente descontento entre los
militares y una situación poco halagüeña
en casa.
La partida no ha hecho más que comenzar.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué valoración haces de la caída de Prigozhin?
¿Crees que esto consolida por mucho tiempo
la posición de Putin en Rusia?
¿Cuáles piensas que serán los próximos
pasos del Kremlin?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora, si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante,
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.